♪
>> Dana: IF YOU THOUGHT THE
CUOMO BROTHER'S INTERVIEW WAS IN
POOR JOURNALISTIC TASTE, A NEW
REPORT SAYS CHRIS CUOMO TOOK
PART IN STRATEGY CONFERENCE
CALLS WITH HIS GOVERNOR BROTHER
ON HOW TO RESPOND TO
SEXUAL HARASSMENT ALLEGATIONS,
CNN GIVING A STATEMENT SAYING
CHRIS CUOMO HAS STOPPED COVERING
HIS BROTHER ON AIR AND ADDED "IT
WAS AN INAPPROPRIATE TO ENGAGE
IN CONVERSATIONS THAT INCLUDE
MEMBERS OF THE GOVERNOR'S STAFF
WHICH CHRIS ACKNOWLEDGES HE WILL
NOT PARTICIPATE IN SUCH
CONVERSATIONS GOING FORWARD.
JESSE, WHAT YOU THINK THAT?
>> Jesse: I THINK THEY HAVE
THREE PROBLEMS.
ONE, THEY SHOULD NEVER HAVE
TAGGED CUOMO AS A JOURNALIST AT
CNN.
HE IS AN OPINION GUY AND IF YOU
TAG SOMEONE AS A JOURNALIST THEY
HAVE TO ABIDE BY VERY STRICT
JOURNALISTIC GUIDELINES.
IF YOU ARE AN OPINION GUY YOU
CAN MAYBE TELL A POLITICIAN,
HEY, WALK WATCH OUT FOR THE FAKE
NEWS, IT'S A DIFFERENT DYNAMIC.
I COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND HELPING
YOUR BROTHER OUT, HE'S YOUR
BROTHER, YOU'RE GOING TO HELP
THEM OUT BUT NOW THE STENCH OF
CUOMO THE ELDER HAS GOTTEN ON
CUOMO THE YOUNGER AND THAT
STENCH IS NOW WAFTING DOWN THE
HALLWAYS AT CNN AND THAT IS ALSO
THE PROBLEM, THE THIRD PROBLEM
IS STAFFERS AT CNN ARE GOING TO
HATE THIS, ESPECIALLY FEMALE
STAFFERS AND THAT'S AN INTERNAL
PROBLEM THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO
DEAL WITH.
I DID FIND IT IRONIC THAT CUOMO
ON HIS SHOW HAS MOCKED THE IDEA
OF CANCEL CULTURE YET ADVISED
HIS OLDER BROTHER TO USE
CANCEL CULTURE AS AN EXCUSE TO
MAKE HIS PROBLEMS GO AWAY.
HE DOES SEEM LIKE THE GOLDEN BOY
OVER THERE AT CNN, I DON'T KNOW,
HE WAS IN 29TH PLACE ON TUESDAY.
NO ONE'S WATCHING HIS SHOW, FOR
SOME REASON HE'S PROTECTED OVER
THERE, MAYBE HE'S JUST A REALLY
NICE GUY.
>> Dana: 29TH BUT WHO'S
COUNTING.
I THINK IT'S REPREHENSIBLE AND
THEY OBVIOUSLY SKIPPED THE
LESSON IN ETHICS, THEY SHOULD BE
ASHAMED OF THEMSELVES, WITH A
WHO ASKED GOVERNOR CUOMO, HIS
BOOK IS WRITTEN ON THE BACKS OF
DEAD NEW YORKERS AND HE SNAPPED
AT THEM AND SAID THESE ARE
LESSONS WE SHOULD LEARN FROM THE
PANDEMIC.
THE FIRST ONE IS DON'T PUT
COVID-POSITIVE PATIENCE IN
NURSING HOMES WITH HEALTHY
PEOPLE WHO THEN SUCCUMBED TO THE
ILLNESS AND DIE.
HE HASN'T TAKEN RESPONSIBILITY
FOR THAT OR THE
SEXUAL HARASSMENT ALLEGATIONS,
HE'S BLAMED HIS ACCUSERS AND IF
THAT'S THE ADVICE IS BROTHER IS
GIVING HIM THEY SHOULD BOTH BE
ASHAMED OF THEMSELVES.
KATIE?
>> Katie: SO WE ALL KNOW THAT
GOVERNOR CUOMO HAS BAD JUDGMENT
BUT THE IDEA THAT HE WOULD CALL
HIS BROTHER CHRIS CUOMO WHEN HE
HAS ALL THESE RESOURCES, LAWYERS
TO TALK TO, THE GOVERNMENT OF
NEW YORK TO TALK TO ABOUT
HANDLING SITUATIONS AND THE FACT
THAT THEY WEREN'T SMART ENOUGH
TO HAVE A PERSONAL CALL RATHER
THAN JUMPING ON A CONFERENCE
CALL WHERE THERE WERE OTHER
PEOPLE LISTENING, AGAIN SHOWS
THAT THEIR JUDGMENT IS REALLY
BAD IN IF IT WAS HAPPENING AT
ANOTHER NETWORK WITH THIS
MASSIVE CONFLICT OF INTEREST ON
A BASIC LEVEL WITH CHRIS CUOMO
BEING RELATED TO THE GOVERNOR
AND HAVING TO COVER THE STATE OF
NEW YORK, THAT'S CONFLICT BY
ITSELF BUT YOU HAD ALL THIS
OTHER STUFF IN THERE AND YOU DO
WONDER WHAT JESSIE SAID, WHY DID
THEY CONTINUE TO PROTECT HIM
THIS WAY?
>> Dana: THAT'S A GREAT POINT
THAT KATIE MADE WHICH IS, I CAN
UNDERSTAND WANTING TO TALK TO
YOUR BROTHER BUT TO DO IT WITH
GOVERNMENT STAFFERS ON THE PHONE
SEEMS LIKE BAD JUDGMENT.
>> Juan: YEAH, IT WAS WRONG,
IT'S HARD TO CONDEMN A MAN WHO
WANTS TO HELP HIS BROTHER.
BLOOD RUNS DEEP, YOU KNOW?
AND IN THE CUOMO FAMILY POLITICS
AND MEDIA I THINK OUR FAMILY
BUSINESS BUT CLEARLY THIS
CROSSED A LINE IN TERMS OF
JOURNALISTIC ETHICS, HE SHOULD
NEVER HAVE BEEN ON THAT CALL, HE
ACKNOWLEDGES THAT AND SAYS THAT
HE WOULDN'T DO IT AGAIN.
IT'S GOING TO HURT HIM AND HIS
FAMILY IN THIS BUSINESS T